estamos aqui no cry vagina que é
basicamente um jogo de terror vocês são
sempre jogos setor aliás vocês podem
viver porque já não faz vídeos mas já
estou dizendo um vídeo de um jogo meu
deus que a música réplica não estamos
numa mansão do senhor com de drácula e
agora vamos ver isto é um pesadelo
orçamento de bronze acho que lá fora a
atualizar meu ver é hoje e até mesmo
jogo de terror a só caiu não vou dar
muita atenção que o texto eu não faço
ideia se estiver baseado em história ou
não mas eu não quero ser eu quero é
jogar o que é isto esta pista nove meses
a menina eu via subir o hotel é que o
obriguem a ocotal e alguém nas escadas é
um boneco isso não chega nada né
algumas pessoas me disseram fui da
provável houve qualquer coisa solar
algumas pessoas já me disseram que este
jogo é muito bom é eu estou a ver isso
eu não vou subir aquelas casas por
tê-los maneira me esperando e já porque
a porta estava aberta em sinal pra eu
entrar é alguém senhor drácula está já
aí num o ensinou que o fizesse mudar
parte desta casa tudo vamos lá então
encaixar o nosso ver ao longe eu acho
que tem que encaixar o aqui né
lá em casa é essa coisa em caixa foi
muito bom em casa não funciona não
consigo fazer nada aqui comigo pontos
nos darão encaixar ali aquela coisa eu
vou ter de ficar aqui qualquer porcaria
não sei o que é mas roteiro rock é eu
tinha que pagar esta [ __ ] comigo e eu
deixei isso no chão homem tão
inteligente da coca vamos lá eu fui lá
dentro buscar outra vez no nosso modo e
agora sim nós vamos encaixar nessa hora
não travou pronto agora sim consegui a
tentar isto é que é exatamente isto é
assim
leu aqui estamos numa nova zona escura
paquerar esse quadro foi o vendeu para
guardar que pagar
annabi está entre os quais não armário
quem fecha a porta é muito embora sem
passar por aqui qualquer maneira por
isso ora lavar que quanto mais tempo vai
passar eo pior é prática não acontece
nada porque consegue que isto vai passar
aqui ok exato
é por se passar daqui segue no shell
ai que é que eu já vi já vem numa do
escuro é meu jardim
ai que a música para o mental nenhum
bicho macabro quem é que está ali um zé
mané não estava prescrito ano já
provocou uma foto com godói cai nada de
especial som é venerado herald que era o
terceiro hino à dylan
ae o que é isto mesmo
nené não um gay né
não não estou a viver na mentira eu não
estou a ouvir um sim eu tô locais a
bronca agora sinto aqui uma porta vamos
lá embora então cheguei aqui e encontrei
um modelo seguro
vamos embora já tenha de que nossa
maquete e conseguimos encaixar ok agora
vou ter que encaixar em qualquer lugar
que ia ser tipo é que como é que eu vou
conseguir passar aqui se tem um sofá à
frente para lá eu acho que é esta a
porta do quarto tão bonito né
tenha certeza absoluta que não foi o icc
a decorar o quarto num fechar uma porta
chama aqui dentro ficaram aqui dentro de
um baú cheio de sangue em fotos borradas
com seis homens nus homens e mulheres
nos de curá los com com tinta vermelha
estão a dançar não sair mas eles falam
coisas macabras aqui o que era aquilo
que vamos fazer daqui não quer saber de
mais nada só quero encontrar a [ __ ] da
roupa desculpa desculpa e não não eu sou
vosso amigo sai da quebra estudo moneo
finanças eu pareço um viaduto não vai
fazer isso comigo acredito que diz fazer
isso com os outros homens mas comigo não
vai fazer tá bom eu não gosto dessas
coisas eu encosto uma palheta
tá maluco eu estava maluco - eu estava
não tá maluco que o tratamento fosse
daqui com ênfase no quadro o cabelo
ganhou nas costas mente aqui alguma
chave assim acho que morrer ea eu morrer
a atingir o quadro agora né
isa também ontem o meu deus consegui
finalmente o que eu acho que era por
aqui no prudente e agora tá vendo
fantasma charlie charlie isto se for diz
que sim
se não for diz que não se eu disser que
não é porque eu é porque eu disse é
porque está lá o foco só pareceu não
desapareceu desapareceu a coisa estava
livre mas desapareceu espero que isto é
expulsa puxa daqui um só tom não estão
conseguindo controla aquela coisa é ter
aqui alguém dentro nem eficaz caros e
não as multidões
porque raio é que eu tenho um barril é
agarrado a uma faca em corrente que vai
ter outro lado que é isso para não jogar
esta hora uma coisa em cima de mim foi
uma barata é que eu não tenho que ficar
este sim uma fofoquinha passagens que
então é isso só vou ficar porque com
esse episódio e esperam ter passado o
jogo todo não sei até que ponto é que o
google é o super clipe aumente conteúdo
para um troço em vídeo show que vocês
tenham gostado deixa eu falar em
favorito fique bem até a próxima
o futuro